dodge it oh yeah we like that off
balance hitch with the handle the
control and everything that has made him
the most accomplished international
player that has ever come into the the
advantage inside with dsj and those two
doctors good Don Cheech handling into
the frontcourt for the Mavericks behind
the back dribble to the rim it all would
have finished
born and raised outside north america
nate is due soon as an assistant in the
NBA the last 18 years da yet another
great path to the Andre Jordan that's
gonna be attainment to watch this year
Conley six seconds five beverages poops
it up spins in quarter tray hits the
three-pointer six seconds hustled it
down the floor got Garrett Teflon away
with a fake and buries the three of the
Hawks are back with it for
Iike found Jordan
his second so out of the game he's going
to go here's Lucas handles we're gonna
get some Globetrotter stuff to this year
so it's gonna be fun Curley deals go
down look at good boy you faked me out
no player likes to look where the palace
has only got one rats in a possession
ball game
[Applause]
how abouts a handle how about the spin
Vince gets him a little bit of
separation the close by Kleber my
goodness
I'll tell you that's reminiscent of a
handle like Steph Curry but his paper
was in the 2017 draft last year played
overseas tray with a you got will run
more picking local rolls with Whiteside
if you don't it's gonna be tough and
assists number ten comes right here I
mean Matt Ryan would be thrilled to see
that fan o is that's a pinpoint five
seconds for pray over midcourt Winslow
defending wage trailing it too
[Applause]
he's Houdini
they heat the trap right here but
there's three guys he goes between three
and meets a fourth guy at the rim nice
little floater to get his twentieth
point it's four dicks all over it
amp nice spin move back to his right
hand cancer a little bit too late to
finish at the open court
[Applause]
here comes Luka look at for just inside
[Applause]
the chop-chop look at me right now
troupe is going bananas down there right
now ha la turning down a lotto for
ChaCha
[Applause]
very alertly guarding LeBron James on
the knees
LeBron didn't see him the first time
with the second time Jonas Jerebko went
into the game and Luca goes right around
ducks again it's strong and it'll pick
and choose what you go for when it comes
to notes just with that quick step got
it off in time
plenty of time what a shot wow he is a
special young man there's no question
about it by the way that was a heck of a
pass Mike Watson yes sir woof
deep freeze why are we baked it in
The Legend of Luca continuing to be
written for the rookie smart toppling
off as he contested that was clearly a
foul
dodging Buffy should have gotten the
three hand one
[Music]
stay tuned one minute left
[Applause]
unless you let him water left and wide
open forcing him to be the shooter good
cut right here and rudy Gay can live
there I'm even hurt son but at the great
finish that time by yo Luca he practices
that stuff
Lawrence draws the defense touch pass by
Matthews Luke at the end of the shot
clock got it back McGuinness
it's gonna come back to me local are you
ready he was ready knocked it down
desperation three late o'clock
[Applause]
this is all Luka here just attack it in
the open court showing off that
tremendous scale against Austin Rivers
break it down towards a minute to play
in the first quarter Ingram's lost it
great picks it up leads the break trade
leaves it for harder off the turnovers
iced epic trae young behind the back to
Kevin with your player from Colorado
half-court Heat
[Applause]
at Barclays center court bank shot
beyond half-court even that's a good
finish by Luca closing out the second
quarter that receded to regroup in a bad
way
well if you're looking for a lifeline
maybe that's 120 in one and here's Luca
with the up up one more time let me give
it to you like Kevin McHale used to give
it to us Dutch sledgehammer
don't sleep on Luca literally had the
mismatch you thought I was gonna land up
now I'm flashing it on you
Turner looks blades it into tray two
seconds watch race
[Applause]
again no help by Joelle and beef
[Applause]
what a play by Trey young the Florida
that he has perfected and get all the
love on the sideline no man he's putting
together a heck of a game there's a
tenth of a second in sedan Kevin looking
lob to the basket away
[Applause]
[Music]
right hand beats the buzzer
then after two bounces three it pulls in
and Atlanta wins it in overtime basket
is Jordan lead with a three and Trey has
that bounce in his step makes the back
[Applause]
gets up out of their seats one more time
watch this fakes the behind the back
that goes through his legs and drew the
foul on Collison his second recaptures
the dribble we're to shoot but stay with
it and this little quick shot to hit the
glass and went in
here's a little baseline pop shot that
goes watch Trey look at Ricky right
through the legs that's just that's the
signature move right there and Baines
what are you doing good 610 611 guy you
got a challenge something not gonna get
away weights at MIT floor now gets into
it with five four from below go yes
Alex laughs
beautiful pass by Prez you setting the
screen here a little brush man he rolls
right down to Benson but that pass was
between Yogi's legs what a path an
excellent look at it from our incredible
crew here in Dallas is Don Cheech works
the fail banks it in
and I'll have a chance for 3 oz merits
at the end of the day you've given up 54
points with 9 minutes and go in a second
you gotta find a way to shut your mouth
and begin to play with intensity here is
coming up
tipped prey
[Applause]
and assists see where this baby comes
from he wasn't even on the logo he was
beyond the logo good heavens
Drake he hung with another addition to
the highlight reel two seconds down
so there's two
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good call miles he set that one up - oh
great look at it - off the glass look at
[Applause]
[Applause]
tre waits for the screen gets the
contact this is a chance for three young
sport 4-point play of the year out of
i/o and Butler tread tie game and it
takes a time
[Applause]
they're trying to keep it on his tray
his hands they cannot he gets the three
away that's it
with point five Trey young puts Atlanta
ahead 92 to 91 and then he sidesteps
embiid gets the three ball on beats the
buzzer and the Hawks at the lead Hart
Winsett who finished hard at the rim
Trey
[Applause]
back heel may have been on the logo over
the line you're considered in was there
a little daylight on the back of the
foot the tray
three young guns it again and this is a
two-point ballgame
Trey young from inside the logo at
midcourt he drained that bad boy
and then Randall after a miss at the
other end another look at the logo three
and then after the Randall best trait
took it coast-to-coast
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content